Tập chỉ, The World's Street Journal, một số cuối gia chua au đang thúc đầy kiế hoạch thành lập dinh mình,
nhằm bò đảm tự gió hình 2 tạo biển thông ốt, cho bất cảnh các thống khu vực ra đang
sông thông có sự tham gia của Mỹ.
Gián kế nơi trong là của Bà Chủ Côt, khó phục hậu cần hàng 2, giá phá bó miền và tổ chức ủ tưởng hậu tổ thông
thông May.
Mò hình được tham chí ổ từ trên sịch Aspice của Liên Mình Chua au từ trên 2, từ biển đỏ năm 2020.
Một số nước như đất cảnh nhắc tham gia chung khi pháp cho rằng sử hiện diện của Mỹ
của thế gây căng thẳng suy này đi giân.
Tụi tưởng pháp em nên mân mân cường những mạnh để là nhiều vụ phòng thuộc của tế,
không bao gồm các bên bị coi là đối địch.
Một cuộc họp trực tuyến sò phá vãnh chủ trị dự kiến xe diễn xa và người bị thức ư.
Tế tục thảo luận 3 kiến với dự tham gia của nhiều cuối gia, nhường chưa có sắc nhận từ Mỹ.